Speaker 1: I want to talk about a really serious
issue, which is that we now know, we know
that there are people on the political right
willing to do violence merely over political
disagreements.
And that's why I was particularly worried
when I saw a headline indicating that the
Nevada governor, a Democrat, Steve Sisolak,
was confronted and had his life threatened
at a restaurant over the weekend.
And this is, I mean, listen, a part of the
content here is the fact that Sisolak is out
at a restaurant without security.
And it's sad that he probably needs security
all the time, but it is what it is, and I'm
going to play the video for you in a moment.
Two men accosted and berated Steve Sisolak
and his wife, Kathy, hurling racist language
in.
Rats, as they followed him out of a restaurant
into a parking lot.
This is really ugly VIDEO.
Nevada Governor Sizzle Jack and his wife,
Kathy, were involved in a harrowing encounter.
Two men screamed racist and violent threats.
In a statement shared to Twitter, the communications
director explained it happened Sunday when
he was walking through a restaurant to have
dinner.
The governor was approached by a customer
in the establishment who asked to take a photo.
It then became clear that the guy was just
kidding around about wanting to take a photo
and started berating him and saying, Are you
in here without security?
Following him, another guy started yelling,
swearing.
Of course, there was COVID disinformation
riddled within the riddling, the harassment
about hydroxychloroquine, etc.
when they started to leave.
Is the ex-wife is Asian, and one of the guys
started yelling China piece of s, we should
string you up by lampposts, et cetera.
Let's take a look at the video.
This is this is pretty horrifying stuff.
Speaker 3: He's right.
It's amazing.
I can't tell you what a piece shit you are.
Sorry to hear that you new world order schrader
pieces.
Bastard.
Speaker 1: You know.
New world order conspiracy.
Speaker 3: No one in here without security.
Oh, and a second night.
Yeah, your pieces for treason.
And I hope you.
I'm surprised you have the balls to be out
here in public, coming out here without a
cop
Speaker 1: out here without security.
Now one of the other things is many of you
are probably saying I had no idea Sisolak
was the governor of Nevada.
He's not even a controversial guy.
He's a completely just basic.
Democratic governor is not particularly progressive
or anything, and so it's not even really about
any particular policy.
Speaker 3: Well, you got those on you, boy.
I'm not moving.
Wait till we find all the money that fought
his way.
Oh man, you're hiding the hydrogen.
Oh, you in truck
Speaker 1: money that flowed his way for hiding
the hydroxychloroquine.
These are sick people, guys.
You can't.
You can't go, Hey, you know what?
Let's talk about our political differences
again to use this sort of banal example.
It's not Hey, you know what?
You want a 42 percent top tax rate.
I want a 20 percent flat tax.
Let's talk about the origins of our disagreements.
This is not that this is you've hidden the
money you've you've received money for hiding
hydroxychloroquine.
You can't talk sense to these people.
They're beyond reach.
Let's go.
Speaker 3: Yeah, you better get the hell out
of here.
This lack of they graduate and go somewhere
else, where's your security?
Where's your flexibility?
Where's your security at all?
You going to sell us all down the river?
Are you working for trying to pieces
Speaker 1: working for China?
So third, conspiracy.
You know, we've got New World Order.
Receiving money and for hiding hydroxychloroquine,
working for China in transit.
Speaker 3: We should string you up by post
right now.
Pussy Boy.
Speaker 1: And there's the death threat, string
you up by a lamppost, sort of alluding, alluding,
quite frankly, to a lynching.
Speaker 3: You know what they do to traitors?
That's right, Patrick.
I think it's awesome.
You run it into a patriot.
Now, hold on.
Where's your security at?
I heard about you banging a little girl and
wrecking your car.
Does she know about that?
See, Mr. Sissy let you treasonous.
China working cock sucking motherfucker.
Where's your security?
A bitch?
Oh, you work here.
I'm a law abiding citizen.
Oh.
Because your daughter is with you, I'm going
to leave you alone now.
Speaker 1: Respectful, guy, huh?
Your daughter is with you.
So now I'm going to leave you alone.
Patrick, this is considered patriotic in some
parts of the country.
Speaker 3: Chief.
That got.
Speaker 1: So a lot of people like that, I
mean, that's considered that.
Now these are the same people who if someone
just shows up with a sign outside Mitch McConnell's
house, they'd go, Whoa, these are these are
private people and they're being bothered.
And that's really bad.
The tone is bad and you shouldn't be allowed
no and no look at what is going.
These are truly dangerous people.
And you know, I know enough people, both in
media and in politics to know that they, you
know, you said, was like, not you're not really
supposed to admit that you're scared by that.
But I've spoken to people in media and politics
who this happened to me and I was scared by
it.
I really was because these people are crazy,
particularly in states where everybody's got
guns, you know, or at least a lot of people
do.
This is genuinely horrifying stuff.
And I know that some of you were going to
write to me and say, that was actually a right
wing podcaster, the guy who did it.
I don't even care.
I don't.
I don't know the guy's name.
Whether he's a podcast or not, I'm not going
to.
I'm not even going to give any.
Now, are you going to mention the fact that
that guy might have some kind of show or anything
like that?
This is really, really disgusting stuff.
It's dangerous stuff.
And I fear and I mean, listen, it's not.
It's I fear it's happened before that violence
is done against people.
You can go back to the 80s, Gabby Giffords,
etc.
There's so many of these examples and these
people are dangerous.
We can't for a second be allowed to think
it's just rhetoric.
They're just expressing differences of opinion,
differences of opinion, hiding money, taking
money for hiding hydroxychloroquine.
You're working for China.
I mean, come on, guys.
Very, very dangerous stuff.
And I don't know how we root that out.
I really don't.
That that's not a person you can sit down
with and have a rational conversation with.
So I'm open to ideas from you guys.
How do we fix this stuff?
I don't know